for decades scientists have been working
on materials that can change shape
whether it's bending contracting or
wriggling along these kinds of smart
materials could be useful for robotics
engineering and medicine so far many of
these materials transform relatively
slowly sometimes they need to be
connected to a controller with wires or
tubes or they have a limited range of
movements now scientists have developed
a flexible smart material that is
remotely activated can move in multiple
ways and can transform quickly changing
its shape completely in less than a
second this material can be 3d printed
and scientists use magnets to change its
shape
the technique uses a soft silicon rubber
embedded with tiny particles of iron a
magnetic field is used to magnetize a
substance creating a magnetic material
that can be printed into any shape and
the direction of the magnetic field can
be changed during printing the result is
a material with a non uniform polarity
meaning each part of the structure can
respond differently to a magnetic charge
scientists added a red filter to film
the movements the system is so precise
that researchers can program a computer
model to move in a certain way print it
out and the same movement can be
replicated exactly in the physical
structure the team have already made
shapes that can contract deform stop a
ball catch a ball and even jump but
there are countless more possibilities
if it can be modeled it can be made
because the magnetic field is applied
remotely these materials can be used in
small inaccessible places in medicine
this could be useful inside the body for
delivering drugs or in surgery or in
robotics the complex shape changes could
give soft robots flexible appendages in
fact along with existing smart materials
this speedy shape changing technology
has numerous potential uses in a range
of industries all with just the flip of
a magnetic switch